What a bad bag of flowers you piled up on your own It
can't
be
helped,
can it?  But it's a nice color
[music]
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
We're the administrators. We're high school seniors, aren't
we?  Bal Oku believer,
Bal I have to do most of my work at home, so I'm taking care of it properly.
I didn't get any achievement points either,
so
I thought he'd say something like that again, so I got permission from the relevant parties and got a special achievement
.